in my room
I feel weird calling you drew even
though that's who you are because you
are just the spitting image of Dean
Martin I feel like no you're not
drooling but maybe I am a little bit I'm
so sorry
the San De Niro face I feel it's like a
tradition in life it is a tradition and
it starts again not only in Vegas but
it's everywhere it starts tomorrow here
in Vegas
the M Resort is here that's gonna just
drive there you park and you go in it
makes sense
what do you guys have going on what do
you guys have going on there oh we got
all kinds of there's food
there's a lot of food we got we got
Italian sausage and peppers we got
linguine and clams we got shrimp scampi
is that what's your go-to where do you
go first when you walk into something
Pizza we got pizza we got Pasta Pasta
Pasta and more pasta and then after that
there's pasta and we got funeral cake I
mean funnel cake and then
all kinds of goodies and the rides yeah
the rides go in the rides first and then
eat the food afterwards I think no no
you like to eat first Grease snow cones
cotton candy then you go mix it up in
your stomach oh 54-inch High kids and
lower are free that'll make for an
interesting time but I actually kind of
like that idea and Mercedes there's
going to be a lot of good entertainment
you are included in that I'm really
excited about the entertainment because
your lineup is crazy and if you've never
seen Drew perform before amazing rat
pack is back who else is going to be
playing there's going to be a lot of
people I wish I could remember I don't
know anybody we don't have your drink
with you you said you need to remember
without my drink we've got um so many
David Perico we have David Perico's
Raiders house band yeah great band we
got the rat pack is back we're going to
be there Friday night if you want to see
that I do around 9 30. we got the what
else we got we got Zoe Bowie Zoe Bowie
Chris Phillips yeah we got Chris it's
good you got your notes I know I just
well I remember because I want to come
see you perform I'm wondering if you can
give us a little we got a great blues oh
really Janice Joplin Cosmic Blues it's a
tribute to Janice Joplin all kinds of
good stuff going on there and when do
you typically hit the stage hold on we
can't forget MJ Live Michael Jackson
will be there oh my gosh this is going
to be the same Dallas Frank is great
best one for the for the ages we're
looking forward to that you're beautiful
so are you sure I can't get my eyes off
well when the moon hits your eye like a
big pizza pie
when the moon hits your eye like a big
pizza pie That's Amore oh I'm getting
hot in here where in the world seems to
shine like you had
[Laughter]
you're amazing thank you so much Friday
you guys are unfortunately d-u-e-t
that's the duet I'm talking about that's
what I was talking about what are you
talking about what you talking about
this is crazy
is coming to town uh we we are so
excited to see you perform and I I'm
getting really warm over here I'm gonna
send it to you bye everybody thank you
Mercedes I love the San Gennaro Feast
and I also